so me and my wife are a bit at a bit of
a Crossroads with each other and I'm
hoping for some wisdom from you guys
each other know uh with each other when
it comes yeah with each other when it
comes to our side hustle she keeps
talking about doing something called
Amazon for uh selling products on Amazon
I I'm honestly at a loss and I'm
actually a little
terrified uh about losing whatever
little money that we actually do have
right now and I don't know how to talk
to her about that I don't know how to
make her understand like I feel like
that's a waste of time please say this
that you know the waste of time we've
already shot that bullet and so we need
to start talking about emotion that you
have the risk of tying up money uh come
at it that way a little bit more logical
with some real emotion instead of
calling what she thinks is cool a waste